どっこいしょ
ハッハッハー本部ちゃん外せそうです東京に心境を入れてかなり日が経ちましたがこの
部屋で使っているものはただ一つ
布団だけですもったいない記事にもったいなくて僕なんでこの東京に家を借りたかなっ
て言って冷静に考えてみたんですけど目が疲れてるからもう目が疲れてるよ
借りたり
有の静岡にたいる時間がもったいないというか時間がないからこっちの東京に家編集と
かで止まったりできればいいなって編集ですよ
そう終始するために僕は今礼を兼ねたはずなのにほぼ編集し
ノートパソコンで何か隅っこに座っていてもやってるんでろーんとパそぼけっこう方が
来ててめっちゃと同じや最近本当にフレーズしかしないいつも使っているノートパソか
もう限界になる
ちょっと今ないでね新しくデスクトップのパソコンを買いましたそれを東京に置こうと
思ってエフェクトプロパソコンパソコンや乗って編集のゲーミングじゃあモニターマン
2キーボード全部買って早1か月がたちました
う地図つくろうと思ったんですけど箱から出して3分で飽きちゃってこの状態が9月
からずっと続いております
[音楽]
やっぺとた菅谷はちょっとヤバいと感じてしまったので今日はもう連としてでも投票
編集ベアをも作ります
この部屋ですよ部屋もう今日はがんばって研修日愛してから僕はねますただいま深夜2
時14分
殺生明日8時くらいから用事があるでござるいやもうやるしかねぇもうねありがとう
南砺市農協やるからです出口汪
レジ命を作るまで出ればて
苦労して頑張って作っていきましょう分
ホラー決めたらをやるからもうなるって決めたから俺になるよまずは pc デスクを
作ります
[音楽]
振ってペッペッパ
後列っと言わなかったーーん
織田家純利じゃんぷりだからどう最強
アダプタ塗ったっ
5いけるさすがはぁっ
滑らねえぜん
ビッ
てえーい
hey ean
[音楽]
メジャー初ん
wh
ana
[音楽]
音程今からの上に載せるだけでしょ人なんてどこに置くかな場所はイケメよ
さんとこれくらいな最後机をすれば完成です
吉野せるぞ
こんなでちょっとなっちゃうよね ok
クエカフェ
ああああああ
1時間半かかったぞ今大変まずなキーボードパットを言って次マウスパット
シャーシてまず机内はこんな感じでございますなんか中にも色々を受けそうですなぁ
作り自体がすごいいい感じだと思いますこれあれだなぁ
すごいができた瞬間テンション上がるなこういう立つ
こういう立場ので遊ぼうドライしますぞ
あーあんきてきたを持って待ってこのちょまりまえこんなに前待ってコンチョおかしく
ないったーーー
バジェットホテルのでよちゃんですちょっと化けは願いパソコンまでマジでちょっと
ネバーきっと舌本当に俺を破る
10ゴミ箱ゴミ箱ですまだ花魁ティッシュ細いが多い
カットとかもだしなんかテキストとかもたくさんいるんですけどというのがすごいこの
パソコンだとスムーズに出来るんで本当に助かった夏台風となってるって黒
あああああいいいい
イェーイウーえええええ
yeah yeah
[音楽]
来ねえ n
うーんなんせ
キーボードせん
[音楽]
あー大うん入ってほぼカーテン中でいた私のパソコン周りもう一つ足りないものがあり
ますそれは何か
ああ
をよ会え
[音楽]
me
関西ソワレました愛だけでこちらのゲーミングじゃあ静岡にある家と同じ会社の一声で
ございます究極の座り心地をお楽しみくださいといけない
基本的にはほぼ静岡に置いてある形とまったく同じ形で作りましたやっときまし
たぁーっ夫東京に部屋をされた時にすぐ作ればよかったんですけども
お役体制やっととなることができました僕あかっ黒田付けなんですけどもうちょっと
この東京の机周りはで増加も机までと異なってねちょっと青と黒で埋め尽くしてあそこ
までをつくってみましたいかがでしょうか
ほんとでノートパソコンがねちょっと怒りすぎてもまず使い物にならなくて東京デート
も編集する時はもう苦しみながらやってたんですけどこれで快適に編集できればいいな
と思って
リマスター
ああああああん
ヌルヌ
me
ええええええ
あっひっ